Welcome back everyone this will be my full miss
marvel episode 3 video there was a whole bunch of
easter eggs they answered a bunch of questions
about the mythology what her new origin story
is it's way different than what we expected so
we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos and thor love and thunder is going to be
hitting theaters really soon we're doing an imax
ticket giveaway for the movie all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and just leave your
favorite moment from the episode on the video
also be posting all those thor 11 thunder easter
egg videos post credit scene videos after that
movie comes out careful for spoilers for the
episode if you haven't seen it yet we'll just
start at the beginning talk about wtf moments
easter eggs as we go along mostly like the real
big stuff too all this mythology that they explain
the episode it was like a big info dump episode
but the title of episode 3 was destined
it's meant to be a reference to a couple
different things it's a reference to the
name of the race of people from that same
dimension as it seems like the group that the
ten rings in the shang chi characters come from
is also a reference to the x-men group in
the comics clan destin in the comics they
were an x-men group that were descended from
a gin in the mcu now they're saying that their
whole race that they belong to are like these gin
characters they're not inhumans but they all have
the same basic type of energy-based powers that
they call newer like this inner light that you
see miss marvel giving off when she's wearing that
bangle like they all possess this ability through
their biology but the members who are from the
alternate dimension and have a hundred percent
alien dna don't have as much access to the power
as the mixed race beings like kamala who have part
human dna from the main mcu dimension comrade
would be one of those beings too like he has
the exact same powers he exists in the same way
that she does it's kind of the same thing with
the shanghi character too where his mother comes
from an alternate dimension and his father comes
from the main mcu kind of like star-lord where one
of the parents has this crazy celestial level dna
the other parent is just like a normal person
it's just the added twist with the miss marvel
backstory now is that she is from an alternate
dimension or her race is from an alternate
dimension it just seems like it's the same
dimension that we saw during the shang chi movie
the realm of talo stretches far
beyond the shores of our small village
we have cities that surpass any in your universe
they also explain the newer inside them that
inner light power helps keep them looking young so
theoretically if her great-grandmother resurfaces
on the show on present day she looked the exact
same too i'm assuming that mixed race people
like her grandmother will just age normally
like kamala will age normally because she has
part human dna it'll also explain in 10 years if
the actress who plays kamala khan is still inside
the mcu still doing mcu movies will look way older
the funny thing about them being gin is that they
actually referenced that in earlier episodes when
her brother tells her oh are you still afraid of
the gin should i turn the nightlight on i think
that was meant to be a clever wink on the reveal
of the show like yes you should be afraid of
jhin but not for the reason why you think you're
afraid of them because they're going to try and
force you to open that interdimensional portal
theoretically blowing up the planet again another
planet-ending disaster usually when you talk about
gin you talk about them as being evil genies but
the text that her father reads to bruno explains
that they can also be good so i know the biggest
questions now are does this mean she's 100 percent
totally not an inhuman does this mean that she's
from the same race that shang chi comes from from
that alternate dimension and to the bangles come
from the same person who created the ten rings
because the markings on them seem very similar
even though they themselves seem just a little
bit different in just the way that they work in
general like they both seem ancient they both seem
like they're from the same alternate dimension
but for instance only kamala and beings from
their race seem like they can use the bengal in
the same way in wenwu for instance doesn't have
any special dna and he was able to use the
10 rings just fine just not quite as fully
as shang chi himself who likes star-lord has
part alien dna from this alternate dimension
theoretically giving him access to the true power
of the ten rings but i know a lot of you are also
asking with the bengals that kamala khan is using
is this gonna be like a thor's hammer situation
where we find out that thor was generating the
power himself the whole time because they say that
the power is coming from her biology in the bengal
just kind of helped unlock that so can kamala khan
used the same power without the bangle eventually
she made all those comments about asgardians and
thor i feel like there was a missed opportunity
on the show because she's such an avengers fan
girl for her to jokingly call herself the
god of bengals like what are you the god
of hammers if it's the same situation with her
and she can use the power without the bengals
that's also a possibility but we haven't seen
shang chi do the same thing with the 10 rings yet
like will he be able to use the same power without
the 10 rings eventually that's something that they
would answer in the shang chi sequel movies but
kamran's mother explained that their jin group was
exiled to the main mcu dimension from that other
dimension just a little over 100 years ago so
they've been on earth way less than the ten
rings have been on earth theoretically but it
sounds like this temple the bengal itself because
the temple itself is literally a ten rings temple
make it sound like the bengals have been on earth
way longer than they themselves have been on earth
but when i say that it's a ten rings temple if you
look on the ground in the main chamber there's the
ten-ring symbol so in ancient times when woo's
group just controlled this area of the world
i believe all the markings that they focus on
around the walls too are meant to tell the story
of the 10 rings and the bengals themselves as
ancient group of people i think the reason they
find the bengal on the severed kree hand is just
a reference to a couple different things like it's
a link to the comic book captain marvel marvel
mega band's backstory because they say that they
changed her backstory in the first place so that
it makes more sense with what they're doing in the
marvels the captain marvel 2 movie and in previous
episodes they make marvel references to the mega
bands saying oh it feels like thought given
form and that's basically what the naga bands do
they turn mental energy into physical energy and
also during the captain marvel movie the cree say
that they've been visiting earth for a long long
time so there were crete on earth in ancient times
and you have the cree sleeper cells that they
referenced during spider-man no way home and it
sounds like members from this gin race from the
alternate dimension have been visiting earth for
a long time too like the group that kamala's great
grandmother comes from isn't the very first group
on earth from this alternative dimension they're
just one of the latest ones her father even says
the text says that the jinn come from pre-islamic
society which is before the middle ages which like
before the year 500 which means almost 2 000 years
ago which would be around the time that we saw the
10 rings come because wen wu found them about a
thousand years ago so it sounds like the bengals
came from this alternate dimension at some point
in the distant past like the same way that the ten
rings came from this alternate dimension in the
distant past and at some point the cree learned
about what was going on with this alternate
dimension in one of their race intermingled
with someone from their dimension and then one
of their descendants wound up with the bengal so
like all this stuff with the severed kree hand
seems like it happened many many many years ago
but they'll clarify some of this backstory in
future episodes but i think this is all part
of them explaining like yes we are acknowledging
her comic book backstory that she wasn't inhuman
in marvel comics she got her powers through
the terrigen mist the inhumans come as this
cree experiment on humanity but then they swerve
on that in the mcu and say oh no instead she's
from this gin race from this alternate dimension
they're not the inhumans so they're trying to have
their cake and eat it too like yes we're winking
at the comic book backstory and all these easter
eggs but we're not actually doing it that way in
the mcu that's why i think the black bolt cameo
during doctor strange ii where they reference the
inhumans the territory miss is meant to be more
straight up comic book inhumans like you remember
because they want to differentiate kamala khan's
group these gin characters as being completely
different they also tease that all the members
of their race have access to this newer inside
them to different levels in the way they tease
things at the end when the grandmother says aren't
you coming to learn about what was going on with
the train didn't you see it too all the members
of their race from this alternate dimension not
just from her family line saw visions of this
train meaning that kamala's mother also saw the
train as well even her brother might have seen
the train like her mother would have that same
gin dna and it seems like she knows way more than
she's letting on like that might have been the
reason why she ran to america so many years ago
like she was trying to get away from all of this
they also confirmed that when they bail during
that big fight in the 1940s here in the temple
they never saw her great-grandmother again in the
flashbacks they also say they think the british
during that era stole the other bengal from the
temple so i'm assuming that they'll find the other
bangle when they go back to pakistan kamala khan
only wears one bangle in the comics but in the
comics she's got a completely different backstory
she's an inhuman she's not a gin she's not from
an alternate dimension or anything like that in
the comic book version of the bengal it doesn't
have any kind of special powers like this one
it's just like a regular family heirloom that's
passed down through her line that her ancestor
wore during partition and hid money in for those
of you asking too like why do they look the way
they do if they're all from this alien race of gin
like to all the people from this alternate
dimension all look exactly like humans
i think the idea is that because we're talking
about a completely alternate dimension here
they don't all look like this like there are many
different races of people many different cultures
because it's like an entire alternate dimension
alternate universe of people it's just that when
they were exiled to planet earth they say that
they moved around a lot to try and stay hidden
they probably just modified their appearance and
just adopted the cultures of wherever they lived
the accent so they could better blend in just also
explain how this could have been a 10 rings temple
in india because in the backstory of the shang chi
movie they basically explained that his character
is the mythical genghis khan that conquered
pretty much the entire known world at the time
it's just with the rise of modern technology it
became harder for him to manage an empire that
big and still stay in the shadows so eventually he
moved the organization to the shadows and it just
sounds like this temple is left over from that
early period when he was ruling like a normal
conqueror like ruling over the entire world but
because the power of the 10 rings seemed like
they helped keep him young for so long it seems
like he used nor like whatever this inner light
power is within those 10 rings to stay young the
same way the kamala khan and these other people
have that power within them also explaining how
the race of people that shang chi's mother comes
from these alternate dimension beings can also
live so long you also remember her grandmother's
story made it sound like when they were boarding
the train later during partition during this era
here it sounds like her great-grandmother used the
bengal to help her grandmother as a child board
the train but then they say right after that she
completely disappeared no one ever saw her again
even though the bengal itself stayed in their
family's belongings the vision of the train they
see looks like it's meant to be the same train
from that day on partition that she referenced
i also think it's meant to be a visual metaphor
like the train represents their passage between
different dimensions they never fully explain what
their group was exiled for in the first place but
they're meant to be one of the villain groups on
the show so whatever it was it sounds like it was
pretty bad but i think the idea with their group
is they at least want you to sympathize with them
for a hot second like that's why comron seems like
he's trying to turn good against his mother like
no don't do this we don't want to hurt them it's
kind of like that shang chi energy where he's born
to one of the villain groups like no no i'm not
going to be evil like you father but they want
you to at least sympathize with comrade's mother
in their group because they just want to go home
even though they are now theoretically threatening
to destroy the entire earth in the process or at
least blow a giant chunk in it they say they
need about the same amount of power as the
output of the sun so they're basically saying
that if it does go wrong it would destroy the
earth in another eternals level event like the
emergence everyone poured one out for the mcu
and the earth in the last couple of years just
can't catch a break first you have thanos and
avengers end game tmed is still there and the
miss marvel series is supposed to take place
after the events of spider-man no way home meaning
the eternal celestial is still just chilling out
in the indian ocean then you have spider-man and
doctor strange messing with reality threatening to
create even more incursions such as r.i.p earth
in general also side note too when they go back
to pakistan it seems like an episode for maybe
they'll reference that dead celestial in the
indian ocean because they're literally going to
that part of the world i'm not going to hold my
breath on that but that would be pretty funny
like you'll see a lot of comments about that
like wait a minute where's that dead celestial
how come they're not talking about that more
think about all the tick tock and the instagram
influencers that will be trying to get pictures
of themselves on the dead celestial like flash
thompson trying to get a picture of himself on
that celestial we'll also see if comrade's mother
was also lying about what really happened to her
great-grandmother she claimed she never saw her
again and she just disappeared quote unquote but
they could have killed her or she could have been
captured by whoever has the other bangle it also
sounds like they're building up towards a moment
at the end of the series like you saw at the end
of the shang chi movie where you have wen wu and
shang chi both fighting each other with half of
the ten rings or like towards the end of the
series you see ms marvel fighting someone else
like comrade or whoever else can use the bengal
with each of them having similar powers looking
kind of like this later when she's explaining
everything to bruno she references not being
related to thor not being asgardian not being
an alien but technically being from an alternate
dimension you would say that her family are aliens
on this planet you can also see she's wearing an
iron man t-shirt in this scene too because there's
avengers merch the avengers themselves have all
become pop culture icons sounds like from falcon
winter soldier with him failing to earn any money
getting any bank loans or anything like that
that not all of them are earning money off of
their merch sales though some of that must be
like bootleg merch bruno also references eric
selvig's research into interdimensional travel and
wormholes that's a reference to all the research
that he did during the thor movies on the bifrost
and jane foster's research too like they all did
the same kind of research during those movies the
other big subplot in the episode is this whole
damage control spider-man no way home plot with
their agency coming from miss marvel just hitting
all the temples the moss in the area they're
really just trying to show them being super big
they're more of like the real world ground level
threat they'll just harass them through the rest
of the series the clandestine group are like the
supernatural villains on the show with the powers
just a reminder that even though iron man and
stark industries funded the creation of that
damage control group now they're controlled
by the federal government stark industries
don't have anything to do with them so pepper
potts couldn't like give them a phone call and
tell them to chill out the other big part of
the episode is just her brother's wedding and
most of that stuff is just meant to show you
their version of like a modern traditional
kind of muslim pakistani wedding if you were to
go to one in the united states in present day
like just a normal wedding from their culture even
though the clandestine group winds up hijacking it
later there was actually a cameo scene during
the wedding too in the background here this is
actually the real life showrunner of the series at
marvel they also bring the cover band brown jovi
because that's her parents whole thing is that
they love bon jovi also the songs they use from
bon jovi obviously one of their more popular songs
living on a prayer during the action scene i was
surprised they didn't use the brown jovi version
of the song though they use the actual bon jovi
song and obviously the big thing is that bruno
gives the gift of the mask to kamala khan that
she's going to wear in her miss marvel costume
or like the next version of her costume that she
makes for herself but they set up episode 4 with
her grandmother's phone call just telling her and
her mother to come back to pakistan didn't you
all see the train like i said her mother probably
would also have seen the train and just probably
lying to kamala about it we'll also learn more
about what happened that day on the train that her
great-grandmother disappeared and probably would
happen with that other bangle also next week in
pakistan is probably where we meet the red dagger
character who's in all the trailers he's right
out of the comics he's like another pakistani
vigilante who kamala gets to know now a lot of you
are also asking how does this backstory with the
gin and the alternate dimension and the shang chi
characters connect with the captain marvel movies
because it said the whole point in changing her
inhumans backstory to this new backstory was to
make her flow more with what's happening in the
marvels movie it sounds like there's going to be
more cosmic stuff more time runs out more secret
wars level stuff happening during that film so
because they're teasing in the shang chi movie
that there's the signal inside the ten rings
contacting someone or whoever created them in
this alternate dimension what they might do in the
marvel's movie is have an interdimensional villain
lethal t's galactus or some other huge threat from
the comics coming from an alternate dimension like
annihilus or the annihilation wave or the brood or
something really crazy from an alternate dimension
and kamala khan will just be tied to the mythology
of whoever this new interdimensional villain
winds up being in the movie and miss marvel will
have all her powers which will help her fight with
monica rambo and captain marvel during the movie
my assumption too is that they'll also explain how
this is all connected to what's happening during
the shangshi movie at least by the finale they'll
probably raise more questions than they answer
but we'll at least get a couple more answers
but if you have any big questions or there any
big easter eggs in the episode that you spotted
that i didn't talk about in the video just write
them below in the comments let me know how you
think this is all connected to the 10 rings in
this alternate dimension that they teased during
that movie as well my full miss marvel episode 4
video will post next wednesday because we just had
the obi-wan kenobi finale video i don't have to
delay episode videos or anything like that so my
miss marvel episodes will post wednesday mornings
instead of posting thursday mornings now there's
only six missed marvel episodes so like there's
only a couple more episodes left though but then
we'll be getting she-hulk episodes i'll do full
episode videos for that we also have the star
wars andor episodes we have house of the dragon
there's a lot of really big stuff coming up this
summer so we're all gonna be eating really good
all my thor love and thunder full easter eggs for
the entire movie my post credit scene videos all
that stuff that i do for all the regular marvel
movies will start posting after it hits theaters
which will be in a couple weeks too everyone
click here for my full obi-wan kenobi episode
6 finale video and click here for my new thor
love and thunder trailer video and easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!